NOMINATION FIGHT THAT IS
STARTING THIS WEEK.
MEANTIME, GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AS YOU KNOW, SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
PASSED AWAY FROM CANCER.
WAS A SAD MOMENT BECAUSE DEATH
IS ALWAYS SAD NO MATTER WHO
DIES.
DEATH IS COMING FOR ALL OF US
SOMEDAY AND FOR THAT REASON WE
OUGHT TO MARK A PERSON’S PASSING
WITH A BOW OF RESPECT, TAKE A
MOMENT FOR HUMILITY AND
PERSPECTIVE AND MEDITATE ON THE
FRAGILITY OF OUR OWN LIVES AND
THE LIVES OF THOSE WE LOVE.
REMEMBER THAT DEATH IS THE ONE
THING THAT UNITES EVERY HUMAN
BEING.
NO MATTER HOW POWERFUL WE
IMAGINE WE ARE, AT SOME POINT,
WE WILL BE GONE, ALL OF US.
IN OUR CASE, WE ALMOST NEVER
AGREED WITH HER DECISIONS BUT ON
FRIDAY NIGHT’S SHOW, WE DID OUR
BEST TO SHOW SOME REFERENCE
BECAUSE THAT’S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
THE LEFT BY CONTRAST MADE NO
ATTEMPT AT ALL.
A PROMINENT PROGRESSIVES
IMMEDIATELY INTO HYSTERIA AND
HATE.
THEY TOLD US THAT
RUTH BADER GINSBURG’S DEATH WAS
MORE THAN SAD.
THEY SAID IT WAS A NATIONAL
CRISIS THAT IMPERILED THIS
COUNTRY’S FREEDOMS.
RUTH BADER GINSBURG THEY TOLD US
SINGLE-HANDEDLY KEPT AMERICA
FROM DESCENDING INTO FASCISM AND
TYRANNY.
NOW THAT SHE’S GONE, ONLY HER
WORDS CAN KEEP US SAFE.
THAT’S AN ODD CLAIM IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
DEMOCRACY.
NO ONE EVER VOTED FOR
RUTH BADER GINSBURG.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH YOU LIKE HER
OR AGREED WITH HER, SHE WAS IN
THE END A SINGLE JUDGE IN A
COUNTRY OF 350 MILLION PEOPLE.
SHE WAS NOT GOD.
YET ACCORDING TO THE LEFT,
GINSBURG WAS ALL WE HAD.
WE MUST OBEY HER DYING WORDS AS
IF THEY WERE OVER THE JUST TEXT.
HER FINAL WISH SUPERSEDES OUR
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS.
WHAT WOULD RUTH BADER GINSBURG
DO?
WE MUST ASK OURSELVES THAT AND
THEN DO IT.
WATCH.
>> AS A NATION, WE SHOULD HEED
HER FINAL CALL TO US NOT AS A
PERSONAL SERVICE TO HER, BUT AS
A SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY, OUR
COUNTRY AT A CROSSROADS.
>> HONOR HER LAST WORDS, THAT
SHE NOT BE REPLACED UNTIL A NEW
PRESIDENT IS INSTALLED.
>> SHE SAID MY MOST FERVENT WISH
IS THAT I WILL NOT BE REPLACED
UNTIL A NEW PRESIDENT IS IN
STORE.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
>> HER FERVENT WISH IS THAT THE
NEXT PRESIDENT -- THAT WAS THE
LAST THING SHE SAID TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> WE KNOW WHO THIS MAN IS.
WE KNOW WHO THIS MAN IS.
THIS IS A MAN WHO DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT A DYING WOMAN’S FINAL
WISH.
CLEARLY.
>> Tucker: SO TURN DOWN THE
VOLUME AND CONSIDER FOR A MOMENT
THE REASONING HERE, THE ARGUMENT
THAT THEY’RE MAKING.
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THAT CONSTITUTION IS IN GRAVE
JEOPARDY.
THAT’S WHY WE MUST SUBSTITUTE AN
87-YEAR-OLD WOMAN’S FINAL WISH
FOR THE CONSTITUTIONALLY
PRESCRIBED PROCESS FOR FILLING A
SUPREME COURT SEAT.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE ARGUING.
GOT THAT?
PRETTY AMUSING.
KEEP IN MIND, WE DON’T KNOW
ACTUALLY WHAT
RUTH BADER GINSBURG’S FINAL
WORDS WERE.
DID SHE REALLY LEAVE THIS WORLD
FRETTING ABOUT A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION?
WE DON’T BELIEVE THAT FOR A
SECOND.
IT WERE TRUE, IT WOULD BE
PATHETIC BECAUSE LIFE IS BIGGER
THAN POLITICS EVEN THIS YEAR.
WE WOULDN’T WISH FINALLY WORDS
LIKE THAT ON ANY WORD SO WE
CHOOSE TO BELIEVE THAT
RUTH BADER GINSBURG DIDN’T
ACTUALLY SAY THAT BUT IN REAL
LIFE SHE WAS THINKING IN THE END
ABOUT HER FAMILY AND WHERE SHE
MIGHT BE GOING NEXT, HUMAN
CONCERNS, NOT PARTISAN ONES.
BUT IN PRACTICAL TERMS, IT’S
IRRELEVANT WHAT SHE SAID.
RUTH BADER GINSBURG DOESN’T GET
TO PICK HER REPLACEMENT FROM HER
DEATHBED.
THAT’S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DEFENDING AND
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
JUSTICE SCALIA HAD SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, NO ONE
WOULD HAVE CARED.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN EMBARRASSED
FOR HIM.
ON SOME LEVEL, DEMOCRATS KNOW
ALL THIS, ALL THIS TALK ABOUT
HER DYING WISH IS RIDICULOUS AND
INSULTING TO ALL OF US IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THEY WILL STOP SOON,
DEMOCRATS HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
ARGUMENT AT THE READY AND ONE
THEY’VE BEEN HONING ALL YEAR
THAT GOES LIKE THIS.
"DO WHAT WE WANT OR WE WILL HURT
YOU."
THAT’S THE REAL ARGUMENT THEY’RE
MAKING.
A LONGTIME CNN EMPLOYEE WROTE
THIS IN THE HOURS AFTER SHE
DIED.
"IF THEY EVEN TRY TO REPLACE
RBG, WE BURN THE ENTIRE THING
DOWN.
THAT THING BEING OUR COUNTRY
THAT WE BUILT.
ON FRIDAY NIGHT, ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT TWEETED INSTRUCTIONS
FOR HOW TO BEGIN THAT PROCESS.
"WE ARE NOW WALKING TO
MITCH McCONNELL’S HOUSE TO
PROTEST.
MORE THAN 120,000 PEOPLE LIKED
THAT POST SHOCKINGLY.
THE HOUSE IS ENTIRELY DARK
SIGNIFICANT POLICE PRESENCE
OUT FRONT.
CONFIRMED BY A NEIGHBOR, THAT’S
NOT A PROTEST.
IT’S A THREAT.
THE POINT OF IT WAS TO TERRORIZE
MITCH McCONNELL AND HIS
FAMILY.
ONLY KNEW IT WAS COMING BECAUSE
THAT’S HOW THINGS SEEM TO WORK
NOW.
THE POLICE GUARDING HIS HOUSE
ARE THE ONLY REASON IT STILL
STANDING.
WATCH.
>> VOTE HIM OUT!
>> Tucker: WE SHOULDN’T BE
SURPRISED BY THAT.
JUST LAST YEAR THAT ANOTHER
GROUP OF DEMOCRATS GATHERED
OUTSIDE MITCH McCONNELL’S HOME
CHANTING DEATH THREATS.
WAS ALL ON VIDEO.
WE PUT UP WITH IT OF COURSE SO
IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
YOU GET WHAT YOU PUT UP WITH.
THAT’S TRUE OF CHILDREN AND TRUE
OF COUNTRIES AND WE ARE PUTTING
UP WITH THIS THAT WE SHOULDN’T
BE SURPRISED.
WHO’S DOING IT?
TRUMP VOTERS ARE FASCISTS, THEY
TELL US, BUT WHEN WAS THE LAST
TIME TRUMP VOTERS THREATEN
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS IN THEIR
HOMES?
THE TACTICS ARE ALWAYS THE SAME,
AND IT’S ALWAYS THE SAME PEOPLE
DOING IT.
IN ANY CASE THAT HE DIDN’T GET
THE MESSAGE, BIDEN VOTERS
ASSEMBLED AT THE HOME OF
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO
CHAIRS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THEY WILL HONOR
RUTH BADER GINSBURG’S DYING WISH
BY MAKING SURE THAT GRAHAM IS
INTIMIDATED.
WATCH.
THESE AREN’T SPONTANEOUS
DEMONSTRATIONS.
NO, OF COURSE NOT.
THEY ARE ORGANIZED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA INHABITING FOR A
REASON.
THE DEDEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
ENCOURAGED THIS EXTREMISM OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
KNIGHTLY, WE TELL YOU ABOUT IT,
BUT IT NEVER ENDS.
GETS WORSE.
LAST NIGHT, THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE
TARGETING MITCH McCONNELL BY
NAME.
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT, BUT IT
HAPPENS.
INVITED SANDY CORTEZ, A
FIRST-TERM CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
THE BRONX.
HE IS THEY SAID.
>> IF YOU WANT TO GET BACK AT
MITCH McCONNELL’S BLATANT,
NASTY HYPOCRISY, CALL YOUR
SENATOR AND TELL THEM NOT TO
LISTEN TO MITCH McCONNELL, NOT
TO BE AFRAID OF
MITCH McCONNELL
MITCH McCONNELL.
>> AND TO MITCH McCONNELL, WE
NEED TO TELL HIM THAT HE IS
PLAYING WITH FIRE.
>> Tucker: WE NEED TO TELL HIM
THAT HE IS PLAYING WITH FIRE.
REALLY?
THAT’S A THREAT.
AND ON INSTAGRAM, SANDY CORTEZ,
AMERICA’S MOST PAMPERED
REVOLUTIONARY WENT AHEAD AND
SUGGESTED THAT DEMOCRATS GO
FURTHER, MAYBE EVEN EMBRACE
VIOLENCE.
WATCH.
>> LET THIS MOMENT RADICALIZE
YOU.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU LIKE HIM OR
NOT.
THIS IS NOT OVER.
WE WIN IN NOVEMBER.
I’M SORRY TO TELL YOU YOU’RE NOT
GOING BACK TO BRUNCH.
THAT’S NOT HAPPENING.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT GOING
BACK TO BRUNCH.
SO NOW YOU KNOW WHAT A FRESHMAN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WAS DOING
SITTING AT THE PODIUM WITH THE
MOST POWERFUL DEMOCRAT IN THE
SENATE.
WHY WOULD HE CHOOSE SANDY
CORTEZ?
BECAUSE SANDY CORTEZ DOESN’T
REPRESENT A CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT.
NO, HER REAL ROLE IS AS
COMMANDER OF THE YOUTH WING OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE DIRECT
ACTION WING, THE THUGS WHO HAVE
SPENT THE LAST THREE AND A HALF
MONTHS DESTROYING AND IN SOME
CASES KILLING ON BEHALF OF
EFFECTIVELY OF THE JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN.
THEIR FOLLOWERS USE THESE
TACTICS FOR ONE SIMPLE REASON
BECAUSE THEY WORK.
THIS SUMMER, A BAR OWNER IN
OMAHA WAS ATTACKED DURING A BLM
RIOT THERE.
A MAN JUMPED ON HIS BACK AND PUT
HIM IN A CHOKE HOLD.
GARNER SHOT HIM ORDER TO SAVE
HIS OWN LIFE.
WAS CLEARLY SELF-DEFENSE AND
THAT’S WHAT PROSECUTORS
CONCLUDED, BUT THEN BIDEN VOTERS
TOOK DIRECT ACTION.
THEY TOOK TO THE STREETS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IN THIS CASE, IT MEANS THEY
GATHERED OUTSIDE THE HOME OF
DOUGLAS COUNTY ATTORNEY AND THEY
THREATENED HIM, THEIR PRESENCE
WAS A THREAT AND GUESS WHAT?
IT WORKED.
LAST WEEK, HE WAS CHARGED WITH
MANSLAUGHTER READ THIS WEEKEND,
HE KILLED HIMSELF.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY
LIKE THAT?
A STATE SENATOR FROM OMAHA DOES
AND SHE IS GLAD JAKE GARDNER IS
DEAD.
MEGAN HUNT CONGRATULATED THE MOB
ON TWITTER FOR PUSHING JAKE
GARDNER TO SUICIDE.
HUNT ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO IT TO
OTHERS.
AS HUNTER WROTE ON TWITTER, JAKE
GARDNER IS GONE BUT THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST ATTITUDE THAT
EMBOLDENED HIM ARE STILL WITH US
TODAY.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
THIS SHOULD TERRIFY YOU.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS HAVE DECIDED
THAT EVERYTHING IS ALLOWED IN
PURSUIT OF POWER.
NOTHING IS OFF-LIMITS.
GIVE US WHAT WE WANT OR WE WILL
HURT YOU.
IN TERMS NANCY PELOSI CAN
UNDERSTAND, THAT MEANS MAY BE
ANOTHER IMPEACHMENT.
>> SOME HAVE MENTIONED THE
POSSIBILITY IF THEY TRY TO PUSH
THROUGH A NOMINEE AND A LAME
DUCK SESSION THAT YOU WHEN THE
HOUSE MOVE TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AS A WAY
OF STALLING THEM FROM ACTING ON
THIS NOMINATION.
>> WE HAVE OUR OPTIONS.
WE HAVE ARROWS IN OUR QUIVER
THAT I MEANT NOT ABOUT TO
DISCUSS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT FOR WHAT?
FOR FOLLOWING THE CONSTITUTIONS
LETTER, FOR DOING WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION TELLS PRESIDENTS TO
DO WHEN THERE’S A SUPREME COURT
VACANCY.
COULD THAT REALLY HAPPEN?
BUT WITH THE TRIAL LOOK LIKE?
WE ACCUSE YOU OF FOLLOWING THE
LAW?
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT’S WHY SHE’S GOT THE OTHER
ARROWS IN THE QUIVER AS SHE
SAYS.
ONE OF THOSE ARROWS IS DIRECT
FORCE.
ON SATURDAY, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM’S CHIEF OF
STAFF TWEETED THIS "I AM READY
TO FLY TO D.C. IN THE MIDDLE OF
COVID-19 AND LAY MY BODY ON THE
FLOOR OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE TO PREVENT A VOTE FROM
OCCURRING BEFORE THE NEXT TERM
OF CONGRESS."
IF SHE DID THAT, MANY WOULD JOIN
HER AND MAYBE THEY WILL DO IT.
MAYBE THEY WILL COME AND
PHYSICALLY PREVENT LAWMAKERS
FROM VOTING.
THAT’S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
COULD HAPPEN NOW.
PEOPLE ARE CALLING FOR IT.
DOES THAT SEEM LIKE EXTREMISM TO
YOU?
YES.
BUT IF IT DOES, KEEP IN MIND YOU
ARE THE EXTREMIST, YOU’RE THE
ONE WHO IS WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING FOR POWER INCLUDING USE
FORCE.
HERE’S HILLARY CLINTON
EXPLAINING THAT HER SINS ARE IN
FACT YOUR SINS.
>> WHAT’S HAPPENING IN OUR
COUNTRY IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS,
OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE BEING
BASICALLY UNDERMINED BY A LUST
FOR POWER, POWER FOR PERSONAL
GAIN IN THE FACE OF A PRESIDENT
OR POWER FOR INSTITUTIONAL GAIN
IN THE CASE OF MITCH McCONNELL
MITCH McCONNELL.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO IF YOU’RE FOLLOWING AT HOME,
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ON HOW
THIS WORKS.
DEMOCRATS ARE SO WORRIED ABOUT
YOUR ATTEMPTS TO UNDERMINE OUR